dazu wenn sie Statements von Professor
Karl Lauterbach Gesundheitsminister von
Professorin Carmen scheibenbogen und von
Herrn Bruch den Präsidenten des BV bitte
Herr Lauterbach ja vielen Dank wir haben
eine sehr wichtige Runde heute gehabt
eine
Veranstaltung die genau zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt stattgefunden hat zunächst
einmal long koved ist nichts was von der
Pandemie übrig geblieben wäre jetzt
abgearbeitet werden muss und dann weg
ist sondern in der Tat diejenigen die an
long kovid erkrankt sind für Sie haben
wir nach wie vor keine Heilung für
diejenigen die nach einem Jahr noch
schwere Symptome haben es sind viele ist
auch die Prognose einer spontanen
Heilung gering somit haben wir viele
schwere Kranke mecfs ist die am meisten
gefürchtete Ausprägungen aber es gibt
sehr viele schwere Erkrankungen die zu
Invalidität bei jungen Frauen für Frauen
sind gerade in jüngeren Jahren stärker
betroffen
wir haben über die wissenschaftlichen
Hintergründe da darüber haben wir uns
ausgetauscht haben wir darüber geredet
und
Erkenntnisse geworden wir haben auch die
Erkenntnis zum Beispiel gewonnen dass
diejenigen die schon lonkovit gehabt
haben oder es vielleicht noch haben wenn
sie sich wieder infizieren dass dann die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es longkowitz
sich verschlimmert oder also zumindest
noch länger wirkt dass diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit also steigt wir
wissen dass man und Co wird auch nach
Impfung bekommen kann da werden wir mehr
lohnkovitfälle bekommen denn es werden
sich viele jetzt auch im Herbst und
Winter wieder infizieren trotz Impfung
und also die Impfung schützt vor Augen
wird aber sich schützt nicht perfekt das
Thema wird uns noch lange Zeit
begleiten die Zeit für diese
Veranstaltung war heute gut weil wir
haben in den letzten Monaten sehr viele
Erkenntnisse
gewonnenko wird eigentlich funktioniert
es ist eine also Erkrankung in der
organische Erkrankung ist es also keine
also
Erkrankung der zürche im Sinne dass es
organisch alles in Ordnung wäre und man
hat da eine züchterkrankung sondern so
eine organische Erkrankung oder die
Grundlagen auch immer besser verstehen
über diese Grundlagen haben wir heute
sehr einvernehmlich diskutiert auch mit
der Beteiligung internationaler
Expertinnen und Experten ich bin sehr
dankbar dass wir die Arbeit die wir hier
im BMG bei dieser also Sachlage machen
dass uns dort die ständige Unterstützung
des Teams von Frau scheibenbogen immer
zur Seite steht auch vielen Dank dass
Sie heute so viel Zeit mit uns verbracht
haben und so wichtiger Anregung gegeben
haben was macht das BMW was ist unsere
Aufgabe was wollen wir erreichen ist
zunächst einmal wir werden weiter
informieren über longkow wird das machen
wir auf unserer Website und im Rahmen
auch unsere Hotline wir werden
evidenzbasiert informieren das ist ja
jetzige Stand der Wissenschaft was
wissen wir über Virus also Partikel die
noch also im Körper
Patienten sind was wissen wir über
t-zellaktivierung was wissen würde wie
Medikamente werden also diese
Information weitergeben zum zweiten wir
werden also auf der Ebene G7 und G20
weiter dafür arbeiten das longkofi dann
Forschungsthema ist das habe ich mir zum
wichtigen Thema meiner eigenen G7
Präsidentschaft als Gesundheitsminister
gemacht das haben wir damals in das
Abschlussdokument bekommen das ist jetzt
auch bei G20 auf unsere Initiative noch
aufgenommen worden somit wir werden
dafür sorgen dass international mehr
Geld für Forschung für long kovi zur
Verfügung steht wenn aber auch in
Deutschland mehr Forschungsgelder
benötigen wir haben derzeit nur 40
Millionen zur Verfügung 20 Millionen aus
meinem Haus hat und 20 Millionen vom
Gemeinsamen Bundesausschuss ich werde
versuchen in den Haushaltsverhandlungen
die jetzt anstehen weitere 60 Millionen
zu gewinnen so dass wir das
ursprüngliche Ziel 100 Millionen
verlorenkovitforschung doch noch
erreichen deutschland braucht 100
Millionen Euro für die
longkowitforschung das ist ein Minimum
dessen was wir benötigen wir haben
fantastische grundlagenwissenschaftler
in Deutschland vor schadenbogen ihr Team
archiva vor Bernhard das wir haben also
Probierens wir haben sehr gute
grundlagenwissenschaftler es fehlt aber
an Geld für die Versorgungsforschung und
diese 100 Millionen Euro die würden hier
ein Segen sein der weit über Deutschland
hinausgeht weil von dieser Forschung
würden auch international viele
Betroffene profitieren schließlich der
nächste Punkt wir machen ein Medizin
forschungsgesetz dieses
medizinforschungsgesetz wird es erlauben
das Universitäten sehr viel schneller
eigene klinische Studien durchführen wir
haben im Moment bei longkowitz sehr
viele Hypothesen was wirken könnte wir
haben aber keine Studien die jetzt
beweisen ob es wirkt oder also die also
Hypothese verwerfen es gibt einfach
vieles was derzeit untersucht werden
könnte im Rahmen von kontrollierten
klinischen studienrandung ist jetzt
kontrolliert oder nicht organisiert und
dafür werden wir im Medizin
forschungsgesetz was wir in wenigen
Wochen vorstellen werden die
Voraussetzungen setzen insbesondere auch
das sogenannte Nomen Netzwerk das ist
ein Netzwerk der Universitätskliniken
die dort zusammenarbeiten auf einer
Plattform wo klinische Studien dann
besonders schnell entwickelt werden
können und wir wollen dann auch
erreichen dass es schnell beginnen
können letzter Punkt ich habe Herrn
Bruch vom b-farmen gebeten eine
Kommission zu gründen für den auf
labelus
wir haben sehr viele Medikamente wo wir
jetzt wissen dass sie für lonkovic
Betroffene wirken sie werden aber in
Deutschland nicht eingesetzt weil sie
dafür kann und auf Labels Charakter
derzeit haben das muss sich ändern in
Schweden wird sehr viel besser irgendwo
Position behandelt weil diese
Medikamente dort eingesetzt werden
können wir wissen durch unsere
Spezialisten und Spezialisten was wirken
kann bei demjenigen der optimal als
Patient geeignet ist aber die
Medikamente haben keine zu Verfassung
und eine solche zulassungsliste wird das
b-farm in meinem Auftrag
herausarbeiten so dass wir auch in
Deutschland einfach viel mehr
Medikamente viel mehr Therapien dann
einsetzen können für diejenigen die
erkrankt sind das ist der erste Gipfel
des erste oder erste Runde Tisch dieser
Art gewesen wir werden das auswerten und
werden dann eine Folgeveranstaltung
organisieren wo wir dann weitergehen wie
gesagt im Moment sieht man immer klarer
wie longkow wird funktioniert wir haben
aber noch nicht die Therapien das ist
auch der Sachstand eine ähnlichen
Veranstaltung gewesen in den Vereinigten
Staaten in Santa Feder kann man zu
ähnlichen Ergebnisse mich hat es heute
ein Stück weit beeindruckt dass wir nach
drei Stunden Diskussionen im
Wesentlichen dann hier in Deutschland
einen ähnlichen Erkenntnisstand wenn
auch nicht alles positiv ist weil die
Herausforderungen im Vordergrund stehen
aber das werden ähnlichen
Erkenntnisstand auch in unserer gewinnen
konnten wie er in Santa Fe gewonnen
werden konnte und wir werden darauf
aufbauen und werden die lonkovit
Patienten in Deutschland nicht im Stich
lassen Herr Professor Bruch bitte ja
vielen Dank also der Minister hat schon
angesprochen wir sind als Bundesinstitut
für Arzneimittel Medizinprodukte für die
Zulassung und Überwachung von
Arzneimitteln zuständig genehmigen auch
klinische Prüfungen natürlich auch für
kovic und longkofig einige Studien
laufen aber da haben wir die Ergebnisse
noch nicht und was heute eben sehr
beeindruckend auch von
patientenvertretungen rübergebracht
worden ist wir brauchen Hilfe jetzt wir
brauchen jetzt eine Therapie und wir der
Minister schon angedeutet hat haben wir
eben deutliche Hinweise das zugelassene
Arzneimittel die für die Schmerztherapie
für Schlafstörungen für
Infektionskrankheiten auch teilweise
eben in der Psychiatrie für Indikationen
schon eingesetzt werden auch bei
long-patienten positive Effekte gezeigt
haben aus diesem Grunde wollen wir das
eben systematisch angehen Gründen eine
spezielle Kommission die diese mit
Experten dann Arzneimittel anschaut
Evidenz die schon da ist eben bewertet
und damit eben auch Empfehlungen dann
auch entwickeln können wie im Alltag
dann diese Arzneimittel auch mit
Patienten und Patienten eingesetzt
werden können das ist halt dann auch ein
enormer Schritt weil das kam heute eben
auch sehr stark heraus gerade von den
betroffenen Patientinnen und Patienten
Vertretungen wir brauchen eben einfach
jetzt der Arzneimittel und die müssen
weil eben nicht alles jedem hilft
braucht man einfach auch im Grunde und
auch die Mensch was klassifiziert ist
und wo wir eben dann auch spezifizieren
können dieses könnte für diese
Patientengruppe besser sein und andere
Arzneimittel eben für andere
wie machen wir das praktisch wir haben
ja Erfahrungen mit of Label Kommissionen
wo wir das auch für andere
Indikationsbereiche wie zum Beispiel die
Krebserkrankungen oder auch zetten
esserkrankungen schon am Haus haben wir
werden über diese Geschäftsstelle einen
Expertengremium zusammenstellen die mit
longkofig und Kurve geben sehr viele
Erfahrungen hat und dann zusammen diese
Empfehlungen erarbeiten das ist so der
Plan und das werden wir eben auch sehr
zeitnah umsetzen in Abstimmung mit dem
Ministerium
herzlichen Dank Frau Professor
scheibenbogen bitte ja vielen Dank also
ich denke wir haben heute ganz wichtige
Erkenntnisse ausgetauscht viele Dinge
wissen wir schon wir wissen dass
longkowischen großes Problem ist das ist
viele Menschen betrifft auch junge
Menschen und wir haben inzwischen auch
gelernt dass über zwei Jahre viele
Menschen auch anhaltend krank sind zum
Teil auch schwer krank sind
berufsunfähig bis zur bettlegerigkeit
wir wissen inzwischen auch einiges über
die Mechanismen dieser sehr komplexen
Erkrankung wir wissen dass wir
unterschiedliche Ursachen haben die dazu
führen dass die Menschen krank sind wir
wissen dass Immunsystem kommt nach der
Infektion nicht mehr zur Ruhe wir hatten
einen sehr schönen Beitrag von Frau über
Saki aus ja die auch noch mal das
zusammengefasst hat wissen also dass die
sogenannte Autoimmunität eine wichtige
Rolle spielt das virusreste aber ein
Teil der Betroffenen anhaltend
nachweisbar sind wir wissen dass auch
die gestörte Funktion vor allem der
Gefäße dazu führt dass sie Durchblutung
der Organe oft nicht mehr adäquat ist
und warum ist das so wichtig warum sage
ich das weil das natürlich die Grundlage
ist um zielgerechte und hoffentlich
heilende Medikamente zu entwickeln und
am Ende zur Zulassung zu bringen und da
sind wir in Deutschland gewisser Weise
sogar in einer Vorreiterrolle weil wir
vom Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung im vergangenen Jahr eine
anschuhfinanzierung bekommen haben 10
Millionen Euro um eine klinische
studienplattform deutschlandweit
aufzubauen und da wir noch so früh in
dem Verständnis der Erkrankungen sind
ist es uns ganz wichtig dass wir das eng
kombinieren mit Forschung das heißt wir
werden jeden Patienten der bei uns
behandelt wird umfangreich analysieren
auf diese ganzen genannten Biomarker
werden auch eine tiefgehende Diagnostik
machen und wir ziehen genau auf diese
Mechanismen das heißt wir haben
behandlungsstudienlaufen um Entzündung
zu behandeln um Auto Antikörper zu
behandeln um Durchblutungsstörung zu
behandeln wir prüfen Verfahren die
teilweise schon angewendet werden ohne
dass es dazu bislang gute Evidenzen gibt
wie die immunabsorption die Sauerstoff
Hochdrucktherapie das sind alles
vielversprechende Ansätze und wir
versuchen das auch so schnell wie
möglich jetzt
weiterzuführen und zu Ergebnissen zu
bringen aber nicht das zu Trotz wird das
dauern es ist heutzutage extrem
aufwendig solche Schulden erstmal
anzuschieben und auch die Durchführung
das dauert alles seine Zeit und wenn wir
dann Ergebnisse haben dann haben wir
auch noch nicht die Zulassung da hoffe
ich auch auf ihrer Unterstützung dass er
dann auch da schneller vorankommen aber
bei den Patienten kommt stand heute
wenig an viele Patienten sind schwer
krank zu Hause Hausärzte sind teilweise
noch alleine gelassen es fehlen die
Spezialambulanzen wie das für andere
schwere Erkrankungen haben die zunächst
im auch eine gute Diagnose stellen und
dann die ähm
Therapieempfehlungen weitergeben die die
Hausärzte umsetzen können und da müssen
wir ansetzen und da ist es so wir haben
ja auch hier kein ganz neues
Krankheitsbild sondern postinfektiöse
Erkrankungen gibt es ja schon lange gibt
es wahrscheinlich schon immer und wir
haben hier an der Charité die
Besonderheit das ist hier auch schon
sehr lange solche Spezialsprechstunden
gibt für postinfektiöse Erkrankung und
da ähm geht es besonders auch um das
Krankheitsbild me FS das ist eine sehr
schwere postinfektiöse Erkrankung die
wir jetzt auch in Folge von Kurve häufig
sehen das haben wir schon in der
Vergangenheit gesehen auch nach Grippe
zum Beispiel auch nach relativ banalen
Atemwegsinfektionen können solche
Krankheitsbilder auftreten es trifft
bevorzugt jüngere Frauen und da haben
wir in der Vergangenheit zwar nicht sehr
viel Forschung gemacht und nur kleine
Therapiestudien machen können weil das
Interesse von Forschung und auch im
Öffentlichkeit und pharmazeutischen
Industrie immer sehr gering war an
diesen Erkrankungen aber wir haben
trotzdem Evidenzen auf denen wir
aufbauen können und wir haben auch
Evidenzen für die Wirksamkeit bestimmter
Therapie ansetzen das betrifft sowohl
nicht medikamentöse als auch
medikamentöse Therapie Ansätze und dann
kommen wir jetzt aber in einem Bereich
wo kein einziger dieser Medikamente
zugelassen ist für diese spezielle
Anwendung sondern die sind zugelassen
für andere Erkrankung wir kommen also in
den sogenannten off-label Bereich und da
wird schwierig weil im off-label Bereich
haben wir höhere Anforderungen was ja
auch richtig ist an den verschreibenden
Arzt der Patient muss umfangreich
aufgeklärt werden es gibt ein gewisses
Haftungsrisiko und wenn es dann um die
Frage der Erstattung geht dann haben die
Patienten in der Regel am wenig
Möglichkeiten das heißt Sie müssen das
auch selbst bezahlen das können sich
viele von diesen Menschen auch gar nicht
leisten weil die oft in der
Berufsunfähigkeit sind und von wenig
Geld im leben müssen und da würden wir
eben jetzt gerne diese Medikamente von
denen wir auch Erfahrung haben also wir
setzen die ja ein ähm würden wir gerne
so aufarbeiten dass wir mit einer Liste
am Ende kommen wo wir es auch möglich
machen dass diese Medikamente in der
Breite auch verschrieben werden können
und zeitnah wir dann auch vielen
Patienten helfen können diese
Medikamente sind keine Heilung aber sie
versprechen oft eine sehr gute Symptom
Verbesserung insbesondere
Kreislaufprobleme kann man behandeln man
kann auch die fatig behandeln man kann
kognitive Störungen behandeln man kann
Schmerzen behandeln das ist eben jetzt
unsere große Hoffnung dass wir hier
schnell gemeinsam vorankommen
herzlichen Dank wir kommen zu ihren
Fragen Frau Slavik hatte die erste
danke sehr Herr Minister vielleicht
könnten Sie umreißen mit welcher
Strategie sie ganz grundsätzlich jetzt
in diesen Corona Herbst gehen wollen
vielleicht sowohl in Bezug auf
Impfstoffe Impfstoff Bevorratung als
auch auf das Thema
wie kommuniziert man Corona noch vor
einer Gesellschaft die keine Lust mehr
auf das Thema hat
ja dann kommuniziert am besten auf der
Grundlage der vorliegenden Studienlage
das ist das was so uns auch durch die
corona-pandemie bisher gut begleitet hat
wir sind ja besser durchgekommen als
viele andere europäische Länder weil der
Studien sagst dann für unsere politische
Arbeit immer eine große Rolle gespielt
hat wir haben hier eine Impfempfehlung
für die über 60-Jährigen und wir haben
eine Impfempfehlung für diejenigen die
also Risikofaktoren haben somit also in
ist die Impfung klar von der Deko und
wir haben darüber hinaus also einen
guten angepassten x-bw 1.5 Impfstoff der
auch für die neuen Varianten die wir
kennen die sogenannten Ehre ist
Varianten allerdings auch für also die
jetzt also na aber vielleicht kommende
wa 2.8 6 Variante wirken würde wir haben
also guten angepassten Impfstoff ab dem
18 September in den Praxen und wir
werden dann auf auf der Grundlage der
Empfehlung und auf der Grundlage dessen
was wir über den Impfstoff wissen es ist
allerdings auch so ich glaube die im
Bereitschaft wird größer sein als der
ein oder andere glaubt viele Menschen
wollen nicht noch einmal einen Kurve der
Kranken viele Leute haben mittlerweile
auch gelernt dass also eine longkurve
der Erkrankung keine Kleinigkeit ist und
dass das möglicherweise etwas ist was
man schwer weg bekommt wofür wir auch
keine Medikamente haben daher wird
natürlich auch die Aufklärung über
lonkovic eine Rolle spielen wenn wir
darauf hinweisen mit der Impfung ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit an longkowitz zu
erkranken geringer sie ist nicht weg der
die Wahrscheinlichkeit bleibt aber wir
haben eine etwas reduzierte
Wahrscheinlichkeit ich glaube da ist die
Bereitschaft gut sein wird wir hätten
gerne Einzeldosen für also in Bayern Tag
im Stoff gehabt das wäre wunderbar
gewesen weil er lässt sich leichter
verimpfen in den Praxen es kommt zu
weniger Vorwurf und die zulässig
leichter organisieren aber es gibt eben
diesen Impfstoff nicht das Unternehmen
war nicht in der Lage uns also
Einzeldosis Impfstoff zur Verfügung zu
stellen es ist jetzt ein also Impfstoff
also in Einzeldosis von moderner also in
der Vorbereitung wenn dieser Impfstoff
da ist wird natürlich also auch bei uns
eine Rolle spielen aber ich kann nur so
viel sagen wir haben angepasste
Impfstoffe bei und der novawachs und wir
haben einen weiteren Impfstoff der also
kommen wird sind somit gut vorbereitet
und wir haben auch einen guten Panamera
da ja mir ist die Daten die wir
eigentlich immer gebraucht hätten wir
haben jetzt also die also da hatten über
das abwassermonitoren wir haben in den
Hausarztpraxen und in den
lungenfacharztpraxen haben wir bekommen
wie die Zahl der Kurve wird infizierten
wir machen weiterhin ein gutes zu wählen
dass wir neue Varianten schnell erkennen
können und wir haben mit dem dem System
jetzt eine gute Rückmeldung über das was
ich in den Kliniken abspielt so mit der
pandemira da ist gut aufgebaut somit
werden wir die Pandemie gut steuern
können und werden auf der Grundlage
neueste Erkenntnisse immer wieder
aufklären
vielleicht direkt daran anknüpfend Herr
Minister mit welchem Infektionsgeschehen
rechnen Sie den stand jetzt für den
herbst- und Winter sie sagten gerade es
werden sich viele infizieren und
womöglich auch longkurved bekommen gibt
es da schon eine erste Einschätzung und
eine zweite Frage an Herrn Bruch
vielleicht sie sagten zeitnah solle
diese Liste mit dem offline of labels da
sein ist das noch in diesem Jahr oder
geht es dann doch nicht so schnell danke
die Varianten die wir derzeit beobachten
sind eben sehr ansteckend das ist die
also nicht so gute Nachricht die gute
Nachricht ist zum Glück ist es weiterhin
eine omikon Variante so dass der Verlauf
der Erkrankung nicht schwerer sein wird
wie also bei anderen
ommikon Varianten an denen man erkrankt
ist aber nicht dass du trotzdem bleibt
es eben bei den schweren Verläufen auch
bei Menschen die impfen haben
insbesondere und es ist für jeden immer
auch ein long-risiko gegeben das muss
man mit also berücksichtigen aber
tatsächlich also in der Bevölkerung hat
sich eine gute Immunität aufgebaut da
ist die Bevölkerung im Großen und Ganzen
geschützt diese Immunität wird aber
nicht davor schützen können dass ich
viele anstecken werden jetzt darüber zu
spekulieren wie viele werden es zum
Schluss sein und wie viele werden schwer
krank das ist einfach Medizin nicht
nicht möglich dafür fehlen uns die Daten
wir werden das aber genau Auswerten auch
auf der Grundlage des pandemira das und
werden da immer wieder die Bevölkerung
also aktuell also aufklären über den
derzeitigen Stand und wir werden auch
ballonkovic jetzt also wenn lonkovic
Fälle kommen werden wir auch also helfen
zu verhindern dass überhaupt zu long
kovid kommt in dem zum Beispiel war
besonders geeigneten Patienten
frühzeitig packstovit oder andere
Medikamente die hier wirken können
eingesetzt werden
ja diese Liste würden wir sehr schnell
erstellen und die käme natürlich auf
jeden Fall noch dieses Jahr da werden
wir also jetzt einfach auch aufs
Gaspedal treten und wir haben ja Ansätze
wie zum Beispiel paxlowe einfach wissen
die sind eben gerade was von Profit
angeht auch sehr viel versprechend das
unter der Therapie eben dann langfristig
nicht nur bei Patienten mit
Risikofaktoren sondern wir haben auch
erste Hinweise das ist auch bei jüngeren
Patienten dann die das Auftreten von
Long kofit verhindern kann und diese
Ansätze wollen wir eben jetzt gezielt
fördern wir wollen sie auch
wissenschaftlich begleiten dass wir eben
auch zusätzliche Evidenz generieren
können so wie das der angesprochene
Plattform von Frau scheibenbogen
ermöglicht so dass wir eben wirklich
hier eine Situation herstellen für die
betroffenen Patienten und Patienten
der Kollege davon
Herr Minister sie hatten ja vorhin schon
über die Forschung gesprochen und über
die Finanzierung der Forschung Richtung
lancobit wie lang wird es denn dauern
bis man longkow wird ungefähr erforscht
auf dem Stand von anderen Krankheiten
und vielleicht weiter noch viele Ärzte
sind überfordert besonders mit der
Diagnose von long-
ja vielen Dank wir haben über die
Wissenslücken in der Bevölkerung aber
auch in der Ärzteschaft eben sehr offen
gesprochen und das ist auch ein Thema
welches wir also jetzt angehen werden
nach der Auswertung des der das heute
ist es tatsächlich so dass es sehr
schwer ist für Betroffene Ärztinnen und
Ärzte zu finden die sich ausreichend gut
auskennen als dass die Therapie dem
wissenschaftlichen Standard entsprechen
könnte das ist auch eine junge
Erkrankung das ist jetzt nicht
vorwurfsvoll gemeint aber es gibt auch
wenig Material derzeit das wird aber
jetzt zusammen kommen und da arbeiten
wir ja auch mit den Wissenschaftlerinnen
Wissenschaftern zusammen die heute da
waren dass wir an Leitlinien arbeiten
beispielsweise arbeitete in arbeitet sie
Selbstverwaltung derzeit daran
dass
eine Richtlinie entwickelt wird die die
Therapie stärker strukturiert der
Gemeinsame Bundesausschuss beantwortet
bis zum Jahresende an einer Richtlinie
die wir in Auftrag gegeben haben so dass
die Therapie bessere strukturiert wird
wenn man das Krankheitsgeschehen sich
anschaut wir haben relativ gute also
Hinweise welche Faktoren alle eine Rolle
spielen zum Beispiel wissen wir dass bei
vielen lonkovit Patienten noch
virusreste im Körper sind lange nach der
Infektion wissen aber nicht ob diese
Virus recht erst aktiv sind ob das Virus
sich repliziert ob das die lonkovic
Symptome verursacht oder ob das einfach
etwas ist was stattfindet aber mit der
longkow Wiedererkrankung selbst nicht
kausalen Zusammenhänge wissen das
T-Zellen also Absätze dass die
hyperaktiviert sind auch an Stellen wo
man das typischerweise nicht finden
würde dann hirnstand beispielsweise im
Gehirn also in Organ wo es
typischerweise eigentlich lange nach
einer Infektion nicht der Fall ist wir
wissen dass das ballonkovit Patienten
vermehrt gesehen wird wir wissen aber
nicht ist das jetzt also mal eine
Reaktion auf einen anderen Prozess oder
ist das ursächlich ähnlich wissen wir
dass Frauen häufiger betroffen sind
gerade in jungen Jahren wir wissen dass
das mit den hormonellen unterschieden
zwischen Männern und Frauen zu tun hat
wir wissen dass bei niedrigen
testosteronen werden aus die
Wahrscheinlichkeit stärker wissendlich
sind die
Testosteronwerte jetzt reduziert weil
man lonkovit hat oder es geht dass sie
die andere Richtung somit das können wir
auch nicht genau sagen und wir wissen
dass eine andere Viruserkrankung aus der
Gruppe der herpesführung epstein-virus
bei denjenigen die lonkovic haben oft
also aktiviert wird dass man sozusagen
da wieder also eine Antikörperreaktion
im Körper gegen das Virus was sonst dort
schlafen bei 90% der Bevölkerung zu
sehen ist dass das stattfindet wir
wissen aber nicht so ob das jetzt also
ursächlich ist für bestimmte Beschwerden
oder nicht und wir wissen dass die Gefäß
das sehr stark beschädigt werden
ballonkovit insbesondere die ganz
kleinen Gefäße wissen dass es dort so
Mikro also Verklumpungen kommt gerade im
Gehirn das ist wahrscheinlich einer der
Mechanismus
weshalb also man dann diese kognitiven
also sag mal aussätzlich schon mal hat
wenn man betroffen ist dass man geht
auch davon aus dass das ein Risikofaktor
ist zwar eine spätere Demenzerkrankung
ist aber nicht ganz genau ist das jetzt
also eine Folge von aus einer bestimmten
also immonenlager oder ist das dann
somit wir wissen sehr viel bis wir das
aber ungemützt haben in ein
therapeutisches Konzept werden noch ein
paar Jahre vergehen und bis dahin können
wir die Betroffenen nicht unbehandeln
lassen somit müssen wir das einsetzen wo
wir wissen dass verhindert über das
reduziert die Wahrscheinlichkeit
überhaupt noch ein Kurve zu bekommen
kann war bestimmten Patienten so eine
Rolle spielen das muss eingesetzt werden
und bei denjenigen die erkrankt sind und
für bestimmte Medikamente in Frage
kommen muss das auf Label gemacht werden
dafür schaffen wir durch das was der
Bruch eben vorgetragen hat so schnell
wie möglich die Voraussetzung
wahrscheinlich ergänzen zum Zeithorizont
was
ja so dass wir schon vorgearbeitet haben
auch durch die Erkenntnisse die wir bei
einem ecfs haben und wir sind bereits
international in Abstimmung dass wir ein
Experten konsensor finden das ist mit
das Beste was wir an Evidenzen haben
ansonsten gibt es kleine Studien und ja
wir stehen schon mit einer Liste in der
Warteschlange
und eine an Frau Professor scheibenbogen
Herr Lauterbach könnten sie noch mal
darlegen inwiefern sie sich da jetzt
schnell Verbesserung für die Patienten
erhoffen durch die off-label Therapie
und was das für die Übernahme durch die
Krankenkassen bedeutet und Frau
Professor scheibenbogen sie hatten
selber die speziale Ambulanzen
angesprochen warum wäre es so wichtig
dass die Politik da auch das umsetzt was
im Koalitionsvertrag ja drin steht dass
man da ein Netzwerk aufbaut
ja ich glaube dass wir hier sehr schnell
zu einer Verbesserung zumindest der
Symptome von lonkovit Patienten kommen
werden weil wir wissen mittlerweile das
bestimmte Medikamente die eigentlich für
lonkovit gar nicht also gedacht gewesen
sind dass die beiden Patienten gut
wirken donkovic Patienten haben zum
Beispiel oft ganz
schlimme Schlafstörungen und diese
Schlafstörungen führen zu einer
zunehmenden Schwäche der Patienten der
Patienten wir kennen aber Arzneimittel
die bei Schlafstörungen wirken die
gerade bei lonkovic-patienten gut
eingesetzt werden können wenn das jetzt
also in der Kommissionsarbeit die eben
schon von einem Bruch angesprochen
worden ist mit unseren
wissenschaftlichen so Beiräten also
Ergebnis ist dann kann das dann
verordnet werden und kann auch bei den
Krankenkassen abgerechnet werden somit
schaffen wir mit dem was wir jetzt
gerade machen die Voraussetzung für eine
deutlich bessere Versorgung die auch
abgerechnet werden kann und die übrigens
dann den Ärzten und Ärzten die das
machen auch Rechtssicherheit geben wird
denn sonst sind sie ja wenn sie Offleben
behandeln es ist aber nicht oft lebe
zugelassen sind sie ja auch in einer
rechtlichen Grauzone eine Grauzone die
mit da dafür verantwortlich ist das ist
einfach derzeit nicht stattfindet und
schließlich werden wir das machen mit
der Liste dann werden wir natürlich den
Stadt der Liste auch kommunizieren somit
wird in die normale Praxis hinein sehr
viel mehr Wissen diffundieren weil wir
können dann natürlich darüber aufklären
das sind die auf lebe Arzneimittel die
bei bestimmten longovit also Symptomen
wirken und dieses Wissen kommt dann mit
der Erlaubnis die Medikamente zu
verordnen und abzurechnen in die Praxis
hinein ich gehe daher von einer sehr
sehr wesentlichen Verbesserung der
versorgungssituationen von lonkovit
Patienten gerade solche Patienten mit
gravierenden Symptomen gehe ich aus
ja wir brauchen natürlich ähnliche
Strukturen wie wir sie für alle anderen
Menschen haben mit mit schweren
chronischen Erkrankungen das heißt wir
müssen diese Patienten zunächst mal
überweisen können eine Spezialambulanz
so eine umfangreiche Diagnostik
durchgeführt wird und wo dann ein
Therapiekonzept erstellt wird und dann
gemeinsam mit den niedergelassenen
Ärzten das umsetzen und deswegen braucht
es auch noch ein bisschen mehr als
Spezialambulanzen es braucht sogenannte
versorgungsnetzwerke wo also alle
eingebunden sind sowohl die
spezialinstitutionen das muss
interdisziplinär sein das heißt wir
brauchen erst aus unterschiedlichen
Fachrichtungen weil einfach long Kurve
zu komplex ist und bei einem ist es eher
ein Problem des Kreislaufs der
Kardiologe ist gefragt und beim anderen
ist er der Neurologe gefragt weil diese
schweren kognitiven Symptome im
Vordergrund stehen und was wir hier
dringend benötigen ist eine
Anschubfinanzierung bei fast allen
anderen Erkrankungen ist das ja
gewachsen über Jahrzehnte und es gibt
auch adäquate Vergütung und die haben
wir hier noch nicht und gewachsen ist es
auch nicht das heißt es ist natürlich an
vielen Universitäten sind jetzt solche
Ambulanzen gegründet worden aber die
sind teilweise einseitig ausgerichtet
die sind teilweise unterfinanziert und
einigen geht auch die Luft aus über die
Zeit weil einfach diese Mehrbelastung
die da auf uns zugekommen ist nicht auf
Dauer geschultert werden kann so das
heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal
Handschuh Finanzierung wir hoffen
natürlich auch sehr auf die Empfehlung
vom GBA dies Ende des Jahres geben wird
dass wir auch an den Universitäten
adäquate Vergütungen dann in der
hochschulambulanz bekommen und das auch
die Niedergelassenen Zusatzvergütung
bekommen z.B im Sinne einer
chronikerpauschale dass die Betroffenen
dann so versorgt werden können wie es
zum Beispiel stand heute ist wenn Sie
eine Krebserkrankung haben oder eine
Multiple Sklerose
Infektion und nach Impfung also Postfach
wird da eigentlich bei der Forschung und
bei den Expertengruppen differenziert
oder läuft das parallel
wir haben heute auch eine Vertreterin
der Postfach also
Selbsthilfegruppen dabei gehabt und in
der Tat wenn das also Krankheitsbild ein
ähnliches ist dann wird nicht danach
gefragt weil das jetzt eine Impfung oder
was die Erkrankung das ist ganz klar wir
haben also in der Regel ähnliche
Ausprägungen aber nicht so stark
ausgeprägt bei denjenigen die noch
faszinierung also erkranken aber das
Krankheitsbild kann sich ähneln und das
Krankheitsbild sich verändert wird nicht
danach gefragt also was ist der was die
Ursache was dahinter kommt sondern
werden dann alle gleich behandelt
die Kolleginnen hinter vom Markt Meyer
Tagesspiegel
ich hatte zwei Fragen und zwar wollte
ich einmal Fragen mit der Finanzierung
Frau scheibenbogen hat es ja jetzt schon
zweimal angesprochen Herr Lauterbach was
können sie denn da schon für Zusagen
machen oder auch nicht sind sie da im
Gespräch mit ihrem Koalitionspartner und
dann wollte ich noch fragen Frau
Professor scheibenbogen sie haben ja
gesagt dass es das ist keine an also
dass sie in einem schubfinanzierung
brauchen eben weil es diese
Spezialambulanz nicht gibt aber es gibt
es ja schon sehr lange als beschriebene
Krankheit haben sie eine Erklärung dafür
warum das bisher so unter dem Radar lief
bei der Finanzierung müssen wir ja also
drei Dinge unterscheiden zum einen
Finanzierung von Forschung die ist
dringend notwendig weil ich halt eben
schon ausgeführt wir haben also all
diese wichtige und klugen Hypothesen wir
haben jetzt also in den letzten Monaten
sehr viel besser verstanden wie lonkovit
funktioniert aber müssen jetzt quasi
testen was wirkt und dazu braucht man
kontrollierte Studien und dafür brauchen
wir Geld und da wäre eine
Versorgungsforschung in der
Größenordnung von 100 Millionen Euro
wäre notwendig da werde ich mit den
Haushältern verhandeln um die 40
Millionen bisher haben auszudenken ob
das ursprünglich also angezielte Niveau
und dann das zweite ist eben die
Spezialambulanzen das ist ganz klar dass
ich Spezialambulanzen also ausfinanziert
sein müssen da sind wir auch im Gespräch
mit den Ländern der also Vorsätze
gesundheitsministerkonferenzminister
Locher war eben zugegen und wir haben
auch über dieses Thema gesprochen da
werden wir sicherlich
also da werden wir sicherlich
Übereinkommen und zum dritten eben dann
das was ich also
abspielt in der Praxis und da wird
darüber nachgedacht hat ob es dort also
spezielle pauschalen gibt die
abgerechnet werden können über die KV
oder beispielsweise über den Haushalt zu
verbannt und da werden wir das was wir
heute gehört haben also auswerten und
werden zu guten Lösungen kommen
ja zu dem Krankheitsbild mecfs da gab es
in der Vergangenheit große Kontroversen
auch über die Einordnung des
Krankheitsbildes die teilweise bis heute
anhalten und
mecfs wurde auch von vielen eingeordnet
als eine psychische Erkrankung oder
psychosomatische Erkrankungen im Sinne
eines Burnout oder Depression und dafür
gibt es natürlich breite
Versorgungsstrukturen und da sind auch
viele Patienten in der Vergangenheit
betreut worden oftmals mit
wenig Besserung aber so sind diese
Strukturen gewachsen und diese
Spezialambulanzen die wir haben an der
Charité die gab es auch schon vor 30
Jahren die ist also die habe ich
übernommen nur die hat inzwischen eine
Finanzierung über eine Stiftung so dass
Sie auch die Möglichkeit hatten in der
Pandemie schnell zu reagieren genauso in
München aber wir brauchen dringend
solche Ambulanzen die nicht nur
postkowitz sondern auch im icfs
Betroffene sehen und auch letztendlich
mit einem guten Verständnis sieht man
die Erkrankung diagnostiziert dazu
gehören zum Beispiel auch bestimmte
Techniken um diese
Kreislaufstörungen zu erfassen da gibt
es auch ganz einfache Tests solche
stehtests oder dieses Hauptsymptom von
mecfs dieses schwere
belastungsintoleranz mit
Verschlechterung nach Alltagsbelastung
die sich postexzeptionelle maleys nennt
und die jetzt auch eins der häufigsten
Symptome bei den postcode-patienten ist
auch da muss man dann bestimmte
Diagnosekriterien kennen die gibt es bei
uns auf der Seite des vertikzentrums
auch zum Runterladen wir machen auch
regelmäßig Fortbildungen wir haben in
den letzten zwei Jahren sehr viele
Artikel geschrieben auch ganz einfache
Dinge wie diagnostiziert wie behandelt
man diese Erkrankung ich sehe auch dass
das sehr viel in der Breite jetzt
ankommt dass viele Ärzte sich auch
auskennen wir haben einen digitales
Ärzte Netzwerk für Behandler gegründet
Anfang des Jahres und da kommen mehr und
mehr Ärzte dazu also es gibt inzwischen
immer mehr Wissen in der Breite nur im
die Geschwindigkeit im reicht einfach
noch nicht aus für viele Betroffene
und da muss sich noch mehr tun und
insbesondere als Krankheitsbild mecfs
muss auf große Akzeptanz stoßen ganz
wichtig noch mal für mich zu betonen
natürlich sind auch
psychotherapeutische Konzepte richtig
bei solchen schweren chronischen
Erkrankungen da gab es so ein bisschen
Lizenz auch in der Vergangenheit es ist
so dass wir alle gebraucht werden für
die Versorgung dieser Menschen und das
möchte ich noch mal betonen aber es darf
auch nicht sein dass sie ausschließlich
psychisch Diagnosen bekommen und dass
sie dann am Ende vielleicht sogar wenn
falsch wohl gemeinter Absicht mit
aktivierungstherapien behandelt werden
das kann in dem Fall sogar sehr
schädlich sein
Kolleginnen in der vorletzten Reihe
frisch von der Ärztezeitung ich würde
die Rolle des GBA interessieren der ja
dann doch das letzte Wort hat mit seiner
Richtlinie aus ihrer Erfahrung heraus
mit dem bisherigen Kommission wie lange
dauert es denn bis er die Richtlinie
angepasst hat und wird er dann auch
wirklich alle Empfehlungen ihre
Empfehlung übernehmen und gibt es ihre
Erkenntnis nach schon Anträge auf
Bewertungen von auf Labels bei
postkorbit beim GBA
also meiner kennt es nach gibt es bisher
dazu noch keine konkreten Anträge die
dargestellt worden ist aber natürlich
stimmen wir uns mit dem GBA ab wenn wir
eben über die offlebenliste dann auch
sprechen werden und wie umfangreich die
jetzt am Anfang wird werden wir sehen da
liegt eben auch im Grunde der gute
Ansatz dieser
schwerpunktzentren auch dass wir eben
zusätzliche Daten dann auch bekommen
qualitätsgesichert von Experten die wir
da auch eben mit berücksichtigen können
und von daher werden wir halt auch hier
mit dem GBA auch nicht die üblichen Wege
in den bürokratischen Prozess laufen das
dauert in der Tat erfahrungsgemäßer
manchmal sehr lange sondern es geht ja
wirklich um den schnellen Ansatz welche
Evidenz ist da und können wir hier was
für die patientierung Patienten dann
gemeinsam tun
der
ja eben also auch mit zugegen und sie
sind mit dem GBA im Austausch auch beim
GBA wird natürlich die Dringlichkeit
dieser Aktion gesehen dass hat hier
keinen Zweck wenn wir die normalen
Verfahren also durchführen und hat auch
keinen Zweck wenn wir sozusagen über
komplizierter verteilungspolitische also
Aspekte hier lange diskutieren das muss
jetzt einfach schnell gehen und da
werden wir natürlich also im Gespräch
mit dem GBA die Weichen so stellen dass
die Liste sobald wie sie da ist dass sie
dann auch umgesetzt wird die Expertise
ist ja was diese Liste angeht muss man
offen sagen nicht im GBA sondern bei den
externen Beratung des BVBs und den BVM
selbst und also somit brauchen wir dort
keine fachliche undierung durch den GBA
mehr sondern schneller Umsetzung die
werde ich auch im Rahmen meiner Aufsicht
natürlich gewährleisten können
ich schließe noch mal an die Gedanken
von Frau scheibenbogen an es geht um die
mecfs Betroffenen da möchte ich jetzt
noch mal konkreten nachfragen in den
weit werden diese Menschen in die
aktuelle Forschung in das
Versorgungssystem in die Studien jetzt
mit eingeschlossen wir hören hier den
ganzen Tag wir sprechen von lankowitz
Betroffenen und so weiter aber diese
Menschen liegen seit Jahrzehnten
verlassen und vergessen von Politik und
Gesellschaft und Forschung hinter
verschlossenen Fenstern und auch jetzt
ist wieder die Situation
zumindestens ist es ist das was ich
jedes Mal erfahre und höre von
Betroffenen dass sie sich wieder
vergessen fühlen ausgeschlossen von dem
System ja Unterstützung Forschung und
Versorgung und nochmal konkret was haben
sie vor also zunächst einmal die
Vertreterin von der Vertreter von es war
ja dabei und ich setze mich ja selbst
seit Jahren für mehr Forschung bei MTZ
hat sehr früh dieses Krankheitsbild auch
also in seiner Bedeutung also
kennengelernt noch in der Zeit dass ich
in Vereinigten Staaten gelebt habe somit
ist es keine nichts Neues indem sie aber
die Endstrecke mcfs ob die jetzt über
longkowitz verursacht ist oder über
andere Viruserkrankungen ist ja fast
immer die gleiche und daher haben wir
eben auch in der Kunden Diskussion also
ganz klar noch einmal alle die
gemeinsame Position verträgt ich glaube
da hat niemand widersprochen dass das
was wir jetzt machen was wir mit MS
longkowitz geht dass das für alle Mrs
Patienten geht diese Forschung kommt
somit allen auch so gute und aus der
Perspektive der MCF westpatienten muss
man fast sagen so traurig wie es ist
aber ist sehr Western jetzt ansehen weil
jetzt eben sehr viel mehr geforscht wird
für mich was früher hätte geforscht
werden müssen also wir hätten früher
viel mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen müssen
und er sollte dort stärkere
Forschungsprogramme geben müssen wir
haben dort gute Grundlagenforschung wir
haben aber kaum klinische Studien
gemacht wir haben wenige Biomarker die
man abrechnen kann in der im Labor es
gibt wenige Spezialisten somit die
Probleme sind alle bekannt aber das was
jetzt gemacht wird für mecfs ist ja für
alle
mecfs-patienten und es ist leider kein
Zufall das vor schadenbogen uns auch
wissenschaftlich berät nicht nur bei
diesem runden Tisch sondern auch bei der
Arbeit die wir hier im Haus ganz
allgemein dazu machen werden ja
wissenschaftlich von Fasching bei
anderen Gruppen beraten die gerade auf
mcfs ausgerichtet sind die Studien die
gemacht werden sind somit auch
emilcfs-studien ganz allgemein und nicht
nur longkowitz Studien aber heute haben
wir einen longkowitz Gipfel gehabt einen
Kurve drin den Tisch da ist
mitgesprochen worden es ist aber nicht
untergegangen
ich habe noch drei Fragen stelle auf der
Liste hier vorne zwei unter zwinker mit
der letzten Frage die Kolleginnen in der
zweiten nein
ja Antje will vom NDR ich habe zwei
Fragen an den Herrn Minister es ist ja
so dass das klinische Studien heutzutage
fast gar nicht mehr gemacht werden
können ohne die Pharmaindustrie die ist
ja in diesem Fall völlig ausgeschlossen
wie kommt das dass in diesem Fall die
Pharmaindustrie überhaupt nicht mit dem
Boot ist und was tun Sie um die
Pharmaindustrie mit rein zu bekommen das
ist Punkt eins und Punkt 2 60 Millionen
zusätzliche Mittel sind ja eine ganze
Menge wie
ja wie wie sicher oder wie
wahrscheinlich ist das denn dass diese
diese 60 Millionen tatsächlich auch mit
dazu kommen für diese 2,5 Millionen
Betroffenen longkow wird Patienten die
es gibt
zunächst einmal es gibt auch sehr viele
Studiengruppen die unabhängig von der
pharmazeutischen Industrie erstklassige
klinische organisiert kontrollierte
Studien machen nur leider selten in
Deutschland das ist das Problem wir
haben eine fantastische
Grundlagenwissenschaft aber wir sind bei
den klinischen Studien gerade durch die
Universität betrieben legen wir zurück
daher hatten wir kein solches System wie
z.B das Recovery System also in UK wo
koordiniert durch also
Wissenschaftler an der Oxford
Universität wesentliche Erkenntnisse in
der Pandemie noch gewonnen werden
konnten und wir haben das also versucht
aufzubauen haben uns aber nicht in der
Zeit hinbekommen dass sogenannte Nomen
Netzwerk das nun Netzwerk das also
universitäre Netzwerk für Studien die
aus der Uni dann herauskommen und
klinische Studien sind wird aufgebaut im
Rahmen dieses Medizin forschungsgesetzes
was ich eben also noch einmal erwähnt
habe was in den nächsten Wochen dann
auch kommen wird wir brauchen man die
Stärkung der klinischen Studien durch
die Universitäten ob die von der
pharmazeutischen Industrie finanziert
werden oder nicht es gibt auch
zahlreiche Möglichkeiten Gelder zu
gewinnen für klinische Studien das
Problem ist dass die Studien in
Deutschland so kompliziert zu beantragen
sind und so es dauert so lange bis die
Studie dann endlich laufen kann bis
dahin ist die gleiche Studie in der
Regel in den Vereinigten Staaten schon
zu Ende das ist das eigentliche Problem
da gehen wir heran die Pharmaindustrie
war mit an Bord also der Vertreter des
vfas also hat dort noch einmal klar das
Interesse auch der pharmazeutischen
industrieartikuliert solche Studien
durchzuführen wenn die Voraussetzungen
dafür gute sind und da muss man auch die
also pharmazeutische Industrie ein Stück
weit ex-pären weil die Bedingungen
klinische Studien zu machen obsolonkovic
oder anderen Themen in Deutschland sind
im Moment leider muss man sagen
unterirdlich schlecht sie sind bedeutsam
schlechter als beispielsweise in
Dänemark in Schweden in Spanien also in
Israel in den Vereinigten Staaten wir
haben große Defizite und die gehen wir
mit dem medizinforschungsgesetz gehen
wir diese Defizite an und zum Schluss
diese 60 Millionen naja ich werde beim
Haushaltsausschuss dafür werben und ich
versuche da auch eine Allianz aufzubauen
über die Parteigrenzen hinweg denn wir
sind dann reiches Land wir haben
erstklassige Grundlagen Wissenschaftler
wir also
sind aber derzeit in einer Situation wo
wir den grundlagenforschern die jetzt in
den Start schon so in den Stadt
erlöchern so stehen die eigentlich
loslegen wollen jetzt ist ja normal das
heute auch der richtige Zeit diese also
diese Konferenz zu machen wir haben
jetzt so viele Hypothesen die man testen
könnte das sofort losgehen könnte und
wir halten den Wissenschaftlerinnen
Wissenschaftlern derzeit die Mitte
vor nicht vor sondern wir vorenthalten
die Mitte so dass Sie also nicht
wirklich loslegen können dafür muss ich
werben im Haushaltsausschuss
online Entschuldigung Florian Schumann
von ZEIT ONLINE eine Frage an Frau
Professor Kneipen danach eine an den
Herrn Minister erstmal geht es immer
konkret um diese Liste sie haben gesagt
sie haben da schon eine Wunschliste im
Kopf ich habe jetzt mit Familien gehört
ich habe gehört baxlovic und sie haben
aber medikamentös und nicht
medikamentöse auch gesagt der schön wenn
sie noch mal kurz ein bisschen weiter
sozusagen konkretere Beispiele nennen
können was sie da im Kopf haben auf ihre
Wunschliste und einen Minister geht's
noch mal kurz um die Frage Corona Herbst
und Winter und um das Thema Maske würde
ich gerne noch mal fragen was sie der
allgemeinen Bevölkerung in dieser
Hinsicht raten würden wenn die Zahlen
wieder steigen oder anderen auch um sich
Vorbild vielleicht zu schützen weil
expandem der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
immer nur die mit denen wir zum Beispiel
sprechen raten bei immun gesunden
beispielsweise sogar eher ab heute im
Gespräch geführt aus dem Hintergrund
dass wenn das wieder breite Kreise der
Bevölkerung machen auch wieder
Nachholeffekt den anderen Infektionen zu
erwarten sind
wiegen sie das ab genau
bei den Medikamenten muss man
unterscheiden wofür man sie einsetzt das
eine was natürlich ideal ist Prävention
das heißt wir können ja inzwischen schon
Risikogruppen definieren zum Beispiel
übergewichtige da ist diese Studie mit
dem Metformin gemacht worden die gezeigt
hat wenn sie für 15 Tage Metformin
einnehmen halbiert sich ihr Risiko long
Kurve zu bekommen ähnliche Daten gibt es
für paxlovit das wird natürlich in der
Breite eigentlich noch fast gar nicht
angewendet paxlo wird wenig Metformin
gar nicht auch da sollten wir versuchen
in dieser offlabel Kommission diese
Schwelle zu senken und vielleicht sogar
Erstattungsmöglichkeiten zu geben und
dann geht's um therapeutische Ansätze
und da haben wir zum einen äh natürlich
auch Ansätze die nicht medikamentös sind
und da geht es zum Beispiel um diese
ganzen wichtige Frage leidet jemand an
belastungsintoleranz und wie kommt so
ein Mensch da noch im Alltag klar und da
gibt es dieses Konzept des pacings und
das ist nicht so ganz einfach mal
nebenbei erklärt und da gibt es Sommer
mal viele Informationen inzwischen auch
auf unserer Seite oder Deutschen
Gesellschaft für Mic FS das ist keine
heilende Behandlung aber das verhindert
zumindest die Abwärtsspirale und
ermöglicht den Betroffenen wieder in
ihrem Alltag funktionsfähig zu sein und
wenn man das sehr gut umsetzt kann es
auch die Erkrankung verbessern und dann
die ganzen komplexen Symptome da sollte
man wirklich Symptome orientiert
Vorgehen als Arzt also auch den
Erkrankten befragen was sind so die
Dinge die dich am meisten belasten da
hören wir ganz oft das sind die
Schlafstörungen klassische
schlafmedikamente sind da nicht gut weil
die machen oft auch abhängig und keinen
guten Schlaf aber da gibt es
verschiedene andere Ansätze wir haben
ganz oft diese Kreislaufprobleme wir
haben es gerade noch mal gehört von der
Kollegin aus ähm Schweden aus ihrer
Studie das sehen wir auch etwa 30% der
Betroffenen leiden am sogenannten
pastoralen tachyka die Syndrom das heißt
die sagen ihnen wird schwindlich wenn
sich hinstellen und wenn sie dann im
Stehen messen dann sehen sie dass der
Herzschlag viel zu schnell ist das Herz
rast das wird auch dazu dass sie ihr
Blut nicht mehr richtig verteilen und
dir Gewebe nicht genug Sauerstoff
bekommt das können wir ganz einfach
behandeln es gibt medikamen das heißt
IVA bradin das ist auch den zugelassen
aber eben nur für Herzrhythmusstörungen
und deswegen wird es kaum eingesetzt das
ist extrem hilfreich vor allen Dingen
Patienten es gibt viele andere Maßnahmen
Stützstrümpfe mehr Flüssigkeit aber auch
viele weitere Medikamente wir haben zum
Beispiel ein gutes Medikament was auch
bei der Schmerzbehandlung helfen kann
diese sogenannte niedrig dosierte
Naltrexon oder auch was ein wirklichen
gutes Medikament auch ist das nennt sich
abilify das kommt aus der Behandlung
eigentlich von Schizophrenie sind sehr
breit wirksames Medikament was
Entzündungen bremsen kann was die
Durchblutung verbessern kann das auch
ganz niedrig dosiert nebenwirkungsarm
eingesetzt werden kann wir haben im
April einen Artikel im Deutschen
Ärzteblatt geschrieben das sind all
diese Ansätze auch genannt
ja vielen Dank für diese Klarstellung
dass wie gesagt für deine wichtige Liste
werden wir werden wirklich die
Versorgung von lancorid-patienten aus
die Symptome angeht deutlich verbessern
können weil vieles von dem muss man auch
sagen wird anders ruhig schon eingesetzt
und wir sind da wirklich später dran
die also Situationen ist wie folgt zu
beschaffen ist keine Erkältungskrankheit
das ist einfach also man kann nicht
sagen also es wäre eine Erkältung wenn
sie sich jedes Jahr ein oder zweimal
erkälten nehmen Sie davon in der Regel
kein dauerhaft nicht schaden wenn sie
aber jedes Jahr eine Kurve also
Episode haben dann also können wir zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt auch einen
kumulativen Schaden leider nicht
ausschließen wir haben jedes Mal die
Gefahr eines schweren Verlaufes und sie
haben jedes Mal die gefahrenkovic zu
entwickeln und wenn Sie schon mal
irgendwo wird hatten ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es longkowitz
nicht nur zurückkommt sondern das ist
also gravierender verläuft und somit ist
also einfach eine schlechte Krankheit
man das nicht haben und ich rate daher
jedem der also durch die
dekoempfehlungen erfasst wird
tatsächlich zur Impfung ja damit
reduzieren Sie Ihre Wahrscheinlichkeit
eines schweren Verlaufes und damit
reduzieren sie auch ihre
Wahrscheinlichkeit lonkovic zu bekommen
das ist die Impfung Wert aus meiner
Sicht und zum zweiten
der jetzt wieder steigenden
Inzidenz ist es natürlich so dass gerade
diejenigen die Risikofaktoren haben
gerade diejenigen die also schon einmal
eine längere Episode gehabt haben da
rate ich auf jeden Fall zum Masken
tragen wenn also die Fallzahlen steigen
kann das Masken tragen auch zum abwenden
anderer Infektionskrankheiten natürlich
eine sehr gute Maßnahme sein und
schließlich also
infektions also
das infektionssystem funktioniert nicht
wie die Oberarme je mehr die Oberarme
benutzt werden desto mehr Muskeln sind
alles zu kräftiger werden die Oberarme
sondern leider ist es so je häufiger
also
je häufiger das Abwehrsystem
in Anspruch genommen worden ist desto
schwächer wird es in der Regel und in
der Tat ist man zumindest unmittelbar
nach einer Infektion geschwächt auch
anfällige für andere also
Infektionserkrankungen und bei schwer
verlaufenden Infektionen kann auch eine
bleibende also Verschlechterung der
Immunitätslage die Folge sein somit ist
es falsch am Beispiel
irgendeine Infektionskrankheit das sind
das also das Immunsystem zu trainieren
wie die Oberarme sind nicht die Oberarme
und das ist insbesondere falsch dass bei
Kurve zu tun war davon hat niemanden
irgendetwas sie haben das Risiko schwer
zu erkranken sie haben das Risiko
Immunsystem zu schwächen manchmal auch
dauerhaft über das bei der TC
Aktivierung bei einer Untergruppe der
Patienten ganz klar sehen und sie haben
auch also das die tragen auch noch das
Risiko dass sie andere infizieren die
dann möglicherweise Risikofaktoren
tragen noch schwererkrankungen
sondern die gba-frage wenn ich
longkurved habe oder auch Post Weg wann
darf mir mein Arzt so ein off-labeljus
Medikament verschreiben in dem Moment wo
die Liste also fertig ist und sie wird
vom GBA beschlossen die Beschleunigung
der Prozesse haben wir ja schon gerade
vorgetragen dann ist die Verschraubung
möglich
eine Nachfrage in der Pressemitteilung
steht dass die pharmazeutische Industrie
auch dabei war wer war denn da dabei und
wie sind sie da im Gespräch dass die
sich auch stärker engagieren
ja wir haben also wir können die also
Liste der Teilnehmer auch noch mal
veröffentlichen wenn es von Interesse
ist aber gemeldet hat sich um also auch
sich an also Diskussion zu beteilen der
Repräsentant des vfa's und der hat auch
noch mal auf die Bedeutung dieser
Forschung hingewiesen und allerdings
auch kam zur Sprache das hat die
Bedingungen Studien in Deutschland zu
machen im Moment nicht optimal sind das
haben wir aber ja also auch also bereits
in der also in im Verlauf der
Diskussionen haben wir das also in den
Vordergrund gestellt wir wollen durch
das Medizin forschungsgesetz wie also
gerade die also Forschung an
Arzneimittel in Deutschland deutlich
stärken das wird auch ein Standortfaktor
werden Deutschland also muss ja auch
neue also Schwerpunkte setzen für
Wertschöpfung für Forschung für
Produktion und das ist
medizinforschungsgesetz unsere
wichtigste Initiative in diesem Bereich
und wird dort auch dann der
pharmazeutischen Industrie helfen hier
Medikamente zu entwickeln damit beenden
wir die Pressekonferenz herzlichen Dank
für Ihr Interesse tschüss